c'est une chose incroyable parce qu'ils
ont tous ces grands
personnages de jeux vidéo emblématiques d'Hadès, donc pour pouvoir
non seulement avoir cet incroyable casting, les
indications préliminaires sont que nous avons été
attaqués par Galaga, mais vous avez aussi en
quelque sorte les plus grands succès des personnages de jeux d'arcade.
descente de nourriture dans un
film c'est assez fou
c'est revigorant que les gens
aiment toujours jouer à ce jeu, les générations plus âgées et
plus jeunes aussi J'ai beaucoup joué
J'ai joué à tous ces jeux vidéo quand
j'étais enfant J'ai vraiment trouvé que Pac-man
était  si étrange et merveilleusement
addictif,
nous avons fait un truc étouffant de Qbert et vous le faites
sortir et vous le mettez sur un plateau et
tout le monde est comme Oh Qbert et ils
veulent tous juste le serrer dans leurs bras et passer du temps avec
lui et c'est comme s'il n'était pas vraiment mignon, puis-
je  kill it, nous avons essayé de rester fidèles
aux vrais jeux eux-mêmes et au
contexte de faire quelque chose dans le
monde en trois dimensions, nous avons commencé à faire de
l'art conceptuel sur la façon dont ces personnages
fonctionneraient, comment ils seraient éclairés de l'
intérieur, c'est vraiment amusant de regarder le
les jeux que nous connaissions sont devenus
il s'agit de savoir quelles sont les règles pour chacun
de ces personnages mes canons ne
tuent pas les petits fantômes de Pac-man, n'est-ce pas Marcos
nous les appelons modules d'attaque xm950
et nous appelons des mini fantômes parce que
nous  Je ne me souviendrai jamais de ce que tu viens de dire
à la fin du film. Je veux
tout gâcher mais nous créons ce monde de
presque tous les personnages de jeux vidéo des
années 80.